poko s dba Needs farmer action
hpn ta blue modea dna s dream 5 a 5
[music]
me come see who do i watch p the perth
down to do in 5
bamse renoa blog ingni ed 2
The name of the
magazine is Fukuda 12 years. This shop is Ginza Fukuyoshi.
Takoyaki was oiled on an iron plate
.
It's made by adding sauce and Malay takoyaki on top of it.
The taste of the soup stock is very good, and the
roots are from Osaka. My father and Osaka made it together.
[Music]
Rector Pu Display stkn jp 24th question Dapo-san
I'm
making it with love.
My name is exactly
the name of the store.  Is in appetite Tsukishima I
think I've been making takoyaki for
31 years
. The
other side
is shaking my eyes.
Men Party It
's meat such as sprouts and onions. The
more you chew, the more juicy you want to eat. I
think it's the most delicious yakisoba in Japan.
[Music]
Gyoza Mina b japanese with sound with # b end
Shon
Today Yama is from China I love Japanese strong people
We have developed this putter together with that Chinese pure gar and Japanese joint
varieties
1 It seems to be a Bon vacation So-san's store Yoyogi store
shibuya tokyo
yeah yeah yeah yeah the team is actually stuffed with vegetables and meat in the skin of the flour
First com After stretching the symbol, Miku is easy
to put it in hot water and say that it's about daddy eating  Arthur Toga Big Day The
tower is chewy, and the roasted woman is crispy, and the
customers are saying that it's delicious.
-That's salvation  Main ip cams deep end
cure
Sendai, which came out of Hiroshima 36 years ago, is here. I started the Rei shop.
I still take over the taste. My name is Tomohiro Fuji.
The name of the shop is Taiyaki.  My name is Hiroki. It's located in Shimokitazawa, Tokyo. We serve
fresh seafood with its okonomiyaki
on top. Put the sardines and roro kelp on the stretched dough,
and put the cabbage pork on it.  I'm doing it in the form of Taiyaki,
dock it, put it on the egg,
shake the sauce blue glue guarantee
, put the interview and it will be finished.
Well, I think that it is in perfect balance with Amami.
I'm doing it every day with that kind of feeling
File eban Bus Camping 3 r Car
Pain Space Station Flavor
[Music]
Taiyaki is
said to have been made in Tokyo in the late 1800s The name is Eiju
Ginza Taiyaki Sakura Windsor
Taiyaki has been on sale for over 15 years since its origin. Taiyaki is a traditional Japanese dessert in the shape of a fish, but
this
shop makes various types of
taiyaki.
Anko Hokkaido
op Rosan Sewing Taiyaki
Book Pupatin
4th